now to the investigation into a massive
explosion in a southern indiana
neighborhood that killed at least three
people the blast yesterday damaged 39
homes fire official says 11 of them are
inhabitable the explosion happened in
evansville which is about 150 miles
southwest of indianapolis rescue teams
say there could be more victims trapped
in the wreckage nikki batiste has the
story
surveillance video captures the moment
of the explosion smoke billowing into
the sky
also caught on ring video from across
the street
officials say debris was strewn 100 feet
in all directions this is the aftermath
two people confirmed killed in the house
that exploded another in the home next
door we have eight different agencies on
scene including
alcohol tobacco and firearms the cause
is still under investigation cbs news
obtained these photos from a man living
across the street from the explosion
they show not only what's left of the
houses that were destroyed but the
impact the blast had inside his own home
dozens of homes suffered extensive
damage another nearby resident drew
straiter shot this video and says he
feels lucky to be alive i was just
hanging out on the couch watching some
tv and
window come in right behind me and blue
glass on my hair some of the damaged
homes were so unstable search and rescue
efforts had to be called off overnight
the structures aren't safe to enter so
there may be somebody still in there the
local energy company says it's working
closely with officials as they tried to
determine the cause of the blast
for cbs morning's i'm nikki batiste